troopers memorial is an important war  memorial of the colonial new zealand  period  opened in 1908 it was created as a  lasting reminder of the contribution of  southland's war dead  from the boer war in 1900 to 1902  the memorial was the forest for the  relatively new city of invercargill  while only 24 names are present on the  troopers memorial  they represent those killed during or  from the boer war  southland centre contingent of 273  men of its population of roughly 22 000  this contingent the fourth contingents  would be known as the rough riders  as they were all largely civilian  soldiers with little to no training  the troopers memorial stands as a  permanent reminder of new zealand's role  in the board war and particularly those  southern soldiers killed an act of  service